rousseau
le pen macron macron le pen les dés sont
jetés en france et le moins qu'on puisse
dire c'est ici en ukraine on a déjà
choisi son camp entre le président
sortant et une candidate accusé d'être
pro russe d'être très proche trop proche
de vladimir poutine et pourtant il ya
beaucoup de reproches qui sont faits au
chef de l'état français au gouvernement
français et à la france en général on
reproche effectivement à emmanuel macron
de ne pas utiliser le rôle moteur de la
france au sein des institutions
européennes pour peser plus on voudrait
que la france met plus de pression sur
l'allemagne sur la hongrie notamment
pour enfin voter dans les sanctions qui
sont prises à l'encontre de la russie un
embargo total sur le pétrole et le gaz
russe est vraiment sain qu'on demande
ici puisqu'on accuse de plus en plus
fréquemment désormais l'union européenne
de financer la guerre menée ici par
vladimir poutine et puis enfin on
réclame à la france aussi plus de
livraisons d'armes les ukrainiens ont
besoin d'armes dans la grande bataille
de l'est qui s'annonce pour le contrôle
du donbass il reproche à la france de ne
pas faire suffisamment d'efforts à ce
niveau là pour rappel un chiffre depuis
le début du conflit les ukrainiens ont
reçu un milliard d'euros dead militaire
un milliard d'euros c'est ce que l'union
européenne verse à la russie pour le ses
importations de gaz et de pétrole chaque
jour
c'est le